so hello and welcome to bite it pi data
global 2021 my name is natalie and i'm
very happy to be here and be your host
for this session i would now like to
welcome alejandro saucito to our session
and he will talk about accelerating ml
interface and
inference at scale with onyx triton and
temple
alejandro is the director of machine
learning engineering at selden
technologies he is also the chief
scientist at the institute for ethical
ai and machine learning and with that
i'll give the floor to alejandro thank
you for joining us today
thank you very much uh nut city
so i think with that um
i'll kick off the session thank you
everybody for joining um my name is
alejandro saucedo and today i'm going to
be delving into accelerating machine
learning inference at scale with onyx
triton
and selden together with a couple of
other tooling
so we have quite a lot of content to
cover
but as mentioned please feel free to put
all your questions as i go along and
i'll be able to answer uh some uh as i
go and others at the very end in the
last couple of minutes
so let's get started
a bit about myself i think
my background was covered quite well so
just to
provide a brief um engineering director
at salon technologies chief science at
least ethical ai and governing council
member at large at the acm
a little bit about
selden so
we are a machine learning deployment and
monitoring open core
company so we actually build one of the
most popular
machine learning deployment tools for
kubernetes
which has been downloaded you know a
significant number of time and is used
across various large-scale production
environments
uh we have an enterprise product that
basically builds on top of that to add
monitoring and management
and at the institute is basically a um
research center based in the uk uh that
focuses on the uh development
of
frameworks for the responsible design
and operation of machine learning
systems
so with that um what we're going to be
doing today is covering um this
challenge of
machine learning acceleration at scale
from a very practical perspective so
we're going to be taking a use case
of a machine learning model that is a
little bit more complex than the usual
hello world type models like the iris
model or even c510
or mnist
in this case is going to be the gpd2 uh
tensorflow model
uh we're going to optimize this model
using onyx and cover a bit more of what
that exactly means
we're going to then be able to run this
model
locally to test it as a service
leveraging this tool called tempo
and then we're going to be able to
productionize it
without much complexity into a scalable
infrastructure which in this case is
going to be kubernetes uh but with the
core premise that you know as a data
scientist uh what the
main
principle on the focus would be is on
the data science side right so this
would require abstracting as much
as it's feasible on uh the underlying um
infrastructure complexities right so uh
the kubernetes abstractions not needing
to leak into the data science
practitioners so that that is one of the
key things uh as a premise
now to start with the with the what uh
what is uh gpt2 so maybe uh several of
the people looking at this talk may
already be familiar
but gpt2 is a generative model
that allows you to basically generate
text
in a human-like way you're able to
provide a input in this case sentence um
of course in a preprocess format but
what you would get is the next predicted
token uh which you would then be able to
resubmit to the model and get the next
token and the next token until you can
create basically a human-like sentence
now why would we use this and the reason
is primarily for two main reasons the
first one is
that this model is a relatively complex
model right as i mentioned it's not an
iris classifier it actually requires
some uh compute a recent amount of
compute to both train and perform
inference
and also uh the latter is given that it
is possible to actually
create some very
uh well creative applications right and
there has been quite a lot of very
interesting use cases that have
leveraged uh uh gpt2
in basically what could be
things like
games even
as well as
you know in some cases even code
generation tools
which which is on the more interesting
side but
those are more some of the more advanced
models but you can see here and get an
intuition of how uh the applicability of
this model could actually be uh relevant
in many at least interesting or fun
applications so hopefully by the end of
this session you will also have not just
uh the intuition of how to
accelerate and productionize a model but
also be able to get the foundation for
you to get started and building
something that could be uh quirky and
cool
so how are we going to do this uh the
way that we're going to be able to do
this is by first fetching a pre-trained
model uh we're not gonna train it from
scratch because the talk is only half an
hour this would take uh unless i have uh
tons of gpus uh uh uh not enough time
we're gonna then be able to optimize the
model and talk a little bit more about
that and we're going to be
leveraging
tools to productionize our model in a
way that can be accelerated as well as
tested both in a local environment and a
remote scalable environment so that's
what we're going to be doing
as i mentioned the code and examples and
links are
provided in this slides and
i shared those uh previously in the
general chat
but you will see at the end
the link to this presentation which you
will be able to to access
now
uh let's get started with the first step
which is going to be fetching uh the
gpd2 model
so
we are going to be leveraging this
library called hugging face
and the reason why is because hogging
face has a very vast range of available
uh pre-trained models that have been you
know optimized and have been
improved to an extent that we can
actually just leverage them
from this catalog or library of
different things that are available
specifically in our use case we're going
to be using the particular artifacts for
gpt2 and this consists of two specific
components and you can see it here how
we actually write explicitly from
transformers import gpt2 tokenizer and
tf gpt2 uh head model so you can see
that on one side we have a tokenizer and
in the other we have a model
as we dive deeper you will see how we
use the tokenizer for pre-processing and
the model
for the actual inference and then again
the tokenizer to actually convert it
back to a human readable format
but it is as simple as just being able
to fetch it and we can now actually
leverage this components locally
and what that basically looks like is as
follows if we actually take and start
with a sentence a human readable
sentence that basically reads
um you know i love artificial
intelligence uh what we would be able to
do is before passing that sentence to
the model it requires some
pre-processing and what that is in
specific detail is leveraging the
tokenizer to tokenize each of the um
words in our inputs so what we would
have from i love artificial intelligence
we would get a set of machine readable
tokens that we would then be able to
actually send to the model in this case
you can actually see that we're not
using model.predict but we're using
model.generate and if you remember the
way that the model works is it generates
or it predicts a single token right in
this case by using the generate function
we are leveraging a utility that allows
us to just um not just run uh the model
multiple times but also select uh the
next tokens in a uh particular way which
we'll cover in a bit in this case we're
saying we want to generate 20 tokens and
what we end up happening having is as
the output we have our original tokens
and our next 20 tokens these tokens are
not human readable so we're going to
have to pass that back through the
tokenizer using the decode as opposed to
the encode which would then give us this
human readable output that reads i love
artificial intelligence but i'm not sure
if it's worth so
within you know five minutes we have
been able to get an intuition of what
actually we would be able to do with
this machine learning model now it comes
to the question of well
what is happening first of all in this
generate function so
the
underlying
workflow that that this generate
function function basically does
is that it
it runs the inference multiple times for
the model however one thing that we need
to take into consideration is that every
inference
uh iteration that we
execute with the model we actually don't
get just one token we actually get um
the list of all possible tokens with the
pro
with the probability of which of these
tokens is the most probable to happen
right and what we need to do is to
actually choose the probability the
token with what would be uh our
ideal selection
so
in this specific case there is actually
a
specific selection which is uh optimized
in a way where it doesn't just take the
next best performing token but it
actually has a look ahead which is
actually called a beam uh uh technique
for for selecting the next token however
for simplicity in our use case what
we're going to be doing is we're going
to just select the uh next token with
the highest probability right so we're
going to perform an inference we're
going to take the token with the highest
probability then we're going to then run
the inference again with this extra
token and and go on and on and on until
we actually reach in this case the max
length right so that's basically it
that's all you needed to know in regards
to the intuition of what's happening
with the model now let's actually see
how uh we're going to scale it and more
specifically what are the challenges
that we would face when looking at
scaling the model right and what that
actually would look like is uh in
regards to the challenges as a
practitioner we know that there is a
requirement for specialized gpu right or
specialized hardware more specifically
right some models may require large
number of memory large amount large
number of cpus or gpus um perhaps even
like horizontal scaling with multiple
gpus performing like model
parallelization or even data
parallelization
there is not just specialized gpu but
also complex dependency between the
components right we saw that we have a
transformer and we also have a model and
there's a data flow between them
there is then challenges of
reproducibility right the challenges of
making sure that whatever we run once we
can actually uh uh identify what was the
input and the output and then be able to
rerun it and get the same deterministic
uh
results and then of course there is some
higher level compliance requirements
around uh what could be even more domain
specific industry specific or use case
specific nuances so that those are some
of the high level things that need to be
taken into consideration which as a data
scientist we can all acknowledge that um
you know not to say that you know this
wouldn't be their primary area of
interest because it may be of high
interest as i can see there's a large
number of
attendees to this talk
but as a practitioner as a data
scientist their primary focus is the
data science part of it the machine
learning or to even
an extended amount the machine learning
engineering part of it as opposed to the
underlying devops and infrastructure and
what tends to happen in a lot of uh
situations with the context in in the
context of
envelopes tools is that there is a lot
of abstraction particularly
infrastructure abstraction that leads
into the domain of data science right
and this is something that we want to
avoid and this is a principle that we
want to approach particularly one of the
reasons that led us to develop this
framework called tempo and its
underlying server ml server and we're
going to talk about that so the question
is how do we go from our model artifacts
or custom code that we will need to
actually put together as you will see
later on for the transformer code into a
fully fledged microservice that we can
not only deploy but also test locally
and scale and optimize without having to
deal with the underlying complexities of
the
infrastructure where it's being deployed
now that's what we're going to start
doing the first step is let's optimize
this model why would we want to optimize
this model is particularly due to the
challenge that i raised around
specialized hardware and um the
potential um
you know workload that may require uh
and may benefit from um you know the
actual uh best performance in their
respective hardware where it's running
and a
standardized
format that is currently accepted widely
adopted in industry is the onnx format
which stands for open neural network
exchange and this is actually a um
we can call it a schema or specification
that allows us to transform in this case
what could be our our tensorflow model
or our python or pytorch model into what
is this standardized format a
standardized format that then other
optimized servers which we're going to
be using can read and then can also um
you know modify in whatever ways it
needs to be able to ensure
optimal performance right this is why we
would want to do that having said that
you can follow all of the steps that we
are doing
without converting it into onyx you can
still deploy your tensorflow model
directly you can deploy your pi church
model directly in this case we just
wanted to show how you can also add this
extra step of optimizing it so now that
we've optimized it we want to
productionize it and in this case we're
going to be using this tool called tempo
and it's underlying uh you know runtime
called ml server and
in this case we're going to be using
actually not just ml server but also the
triton inference server and this will
become a little bit more
intuitive as we delve into it the key
thing that you want to get from this
slide is that with tempo we're going to
be able to first run it locally and then
scale it up right and we would want to
do this because you wouldn't want to
actually push your artifact and then
certainly realize that it's failing and
then ask you know how to ask for logs
and then have to ask for a lot of things
that would again go into the challenge
of uh leakage of abstractions of the
underlying infrastructure where it's
actually running
so the way that we're going gonna be
approaching this productionizing
step with tempo what we're gonna be
doing is these five steps the first step
is we're gonna actually define our tempo
wrapper for the gpt2 model right and
remember that the gpt2 model is separate
to the transformer so that will be our
first step once we define our wrapper we
can actually run that optimized model in
this optimized server from nvidia which
would allow us to leverage this gpt to
inference in a very sort of like you
know optimal performant way right so
that's what we're going to be able to do
that just on on the first part with
tempo but if you remember from the um
intuition that we gathered initially our
model
doesn't take human readable strings
right it actually takes machine readable
tokens so in order for us to actually
interact with this
service
in an easy and simple way
and remember as well because it only
predicts a single token we actually
would like to have an extra component
that allows us to basically send it the
text and then this component would
handle all of the logic to talk to the
model in those multiple times right to
be able to request the next token and
the next token and the next token and
then convert it back into a human
readable format right so what that means
is that we actually have to then define
that custom transformer logic which is
going to be some python logic that is
going to perform uh that set of steps
that we just described and this will
become a little bit more intuitive when
you look at the code right because right
now it sounds very abstract you know
once we see the code it looks very
you know easy and simple to understand
now these two things our wrapper and our
custom logic we can similarly just run
it again in docker send some strings get
some predictions but instead of just
this uh specific one where we only get
one token and we have to send the tokens
we can now just send strings right we
can send strings to the transformer that
would interact with the model and we
would get the output
and we would be able to generate our 10
tokens and what not and once we're happy
that it ran correctly in docker locally
we can then just very simply transition
into our kubernetes stack and then
deploy that exact uh graph into
kubernetes with just a
similar command that would basically
just run that so that's ultimately the
only step that would have to happen from
from this one to this one now let's look
at what that actually seems from a code
perspective
so
the the first step which is defining the
wrapper right so what this looks like
from tempo we have to actually import
from tempo the actual different types of
model frameworks we will see what that
means and we will then have to import
the model class from tempo and in this
model class the only thing that we have
to provide is the model name
the model runtime which in this case is
of type onyx because we actually
optimized our model
but as i mentioned earlier you can
actually pat you can actually pass a
tensorflow model with model framework
tensorflow or you can pass
a pi charge model with model framework
pi torch so this basically allows you to
define what is that what is the actual
artifact type
then we can provide the path to where we
have our model the local path and the
remote path that will be relevant once
we actually want to deploy it remotely
right because it needs to access the
artifact and then a description right
which is optional so once we define our
wrapper we can actually run it locally
right and this is just our model right
so we're going to be just running the
model locally
with that triton optimized server so
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to
call
tempo.server.deploy import deploy local
and then we're going to be able to run
that object that we created through our
deploy local function that would then
deploy it in docker locally and would
give us this remote client that we're
going to be able to interact with that
model what that really means in practice
is that we can actually send tokens
and remember we have to actually
tokenize it so we're gonna have to go
through those complex steps of taking
our string that is this is a test we're
gonna then have to convert that into
the tokens and then we're gonna have to
change
this as the input to the model and then
call our model with remotemodel.predict
that would then give us the response
which again is in token format this
token format is you know all of the
potential tokens we select the one with
the highest probability we then decode
it and then we can see what the next
token is
which the next token is the word off
right but this is very complex right as
we said we don't want to just have a
model that all the t or all it receives
is tokens we actually just want to send
this string
so that's where the next step comes in
which is building our custom transformer
logic and for this we actually use not
the model clock model uh uh uh uh module
uh or decorator but we use the pipeline
decorator it has the same same exact
uh parameters except this new parameter
called models where we actually are
providing and passing that model that we
defined above right so we're passing it
this gpt2 model and now we can actually
use it locally by providing the custom
logic the custom logic as a first step
is going to consist of loading that
artifact tokenizer right so we're going
to put the logic to load that tokenizer
and then we have to define the predict
function and this predict function is
going to be
basically an abstraction on the
uh you know rest end point that our
service will expose so whatever we
actually are sending to the service
through this simplified interface is
going to be provided as this kind of in
this case
a input string right so in this case we
have to define the logic assuming that
we're going to be taking this as an
input string
and what are we going to be doing here
you already probably having the
intuition we are going to convert this
string into tokens we're going to then
call this remote model uh for every
single time that we want to you know
generate the next token and then we're
going to return you know the decode the
tokens and return the output what that
really looks like it may sound
complicated but it it isn't really uh we
we first defined the number of tokens we
want to generate
we then take that set that that you know
sentence that we that we that we
received
then we iterate for the number of tokens
that we want basically yeah to generate
which is in this case 10.
we first convert or tokenize our initial
um
input which we receive here as all of
the tokens we do the same thing that we
did locally but inside of our custom
logic which is basically run an initial
a single inference
execution which will give us
those outputs we would then generate
choose the one with the highest
probability
decode it and append it and we're going
to then do this in this case 10 times
until we actually have a sentence with
10 extra words which we will then return
and that's it this is probably like the
most complex part of this talk uh uh and
you know i hope that you managed to kind
of understand the intuition behind it
but the key thing is here is you pass a
token you run it through the model
several times and then you return it now
the key thing about this is that similar
to our previous uh sort of example we
can run our pipeline in the same way
locally by using the same function
deploy local gpt to transformer we would
get this uh you know remote class that
we can now then interact so we can now
send a human readable string that in
this case it reads i love artificial
intelligence and then the response is
but i'm not sure if it's worth whatever
that means what we have here is
basically just a very simple way of
interacting with this complex uh you
know data dependencies uh with this data
flow and this underlying infrastructure
which in our case is running locally in
docker however now we want the next step
of let's then take what we are running
locally in docker and then run it in
kubernetes this will actually be
extremely simple this is only a
you know step of actually having to uh
run it through the deploy remote
as opposed to the deploy local and i can
see uh natalie you about to give the the
heads up on the five minutes but yeah we
should be we should be good uh so no
worries awesome thank you um yeah so so
now it's basically the question of how
do we deploy it to the uh remote site
this is just using uh the deploy remote
so in this case we would basically yeah
just select some nuances of what is the
namespace uh where we want to have it
and we would basically just leave the
underlying infrastructure to be handled
uh by tempo to be uh deployed and the
interaction with that is the same thing
we can send the prediction of isle of
artificial intelligence and we would get
a response of uh yeah the same response
right but i'm not sure if it's worth
now that's basically it uh with that you
have now been able to go from uh you
know jupiter notebook to
machine learning engineering local
testing to
mlop's productionization with a still
not optimal but at least minimized
amount of
leakage of the underlying infrastructure
so in summary we were able to
have a look at machine learning
acceleration at scale by optimizing this
gpt-2 tensorflow model with onyx running
this gt2 model and triton with docker
deploying this gpt2 model in kubernetes
and then assessing some of the best
practices with all of these different
components
now to
wrap up i just wanted to mention that
this is one of our many different
collaborations that we have been
exploring with temple we did a recent
collaboration with
the meta flow team to be able to provide
a full end-to-end training and
deployment set of components uh which
you can find in this resource uh all of
these projects are open source so any
feedback is greatly appreciated uh so
you know please do uh feel free to send
any of these resources and with that i
want to give a massive thanks to uh yeah
all the attendees and definitely the
organizers especially yeah the chairs of
this session uh thank you everybody for
this and uh yeah now we can take some
questions
thank you
there's one that is what is the reason
the library is called the hugging phase
oh that's a great question uh i actually
don't know i think it's just because
their
name is their emoji but it's actually a
pretty renowned uh company
an open source project
that uh i encourage people to
maybe uh find out and given this open
source maybe open an issue and ask
uh which is the beauty of open source
yeah
i can see the the chat uh happy to read
it so it says uh it seems that it's much
easier to deploy deep learning models
for scalable load latency and parallel
inference due to the extensive tooling
support rather than try to deploy
something that lacks such support that's
okay that's a really good point so
interestingly enough uh that is why um i
was mentioning several times the
underlying runtime of tempo which is uh
both triton and ml server
ml server is actually the optimized
framework for non-deep learning uh
libraries like scikit-learn xg boost
light gbm etc so you can actually still
deploy this type of artifacts with the
same level of reliability
okay thank you so our time is over if
you have any further discussion please
move it to slack or gather town thank
you so much alejandro for your talk and
being part of pi data global 2021
thank you thank you natalie and thank
you everybody great to be here